guari which translates as round bread is
a traditional Nepali breakfast item
normally it only requires salt and
baking powder but I added some turmeric
for color and garlic to keep the
vampires away this dish originated in
the Noir Community who are known for
their Delicacies culture and cute faces
Nepal is very rich in its ethnic
diversity so there is a chance that we
grew up with different breakfast on our
plate but we also agree that no
breakfast is complete without a hot cup
of milk tea chain or tamin with a heavy
Nepali accent is one of the easiest dish
you can put together packed with lots of
veggies it makes for a pretty healthy
lunch option normally people use egg
noodles to make this dish but all I had
in my pantry was spaghetti so that's
what I'm using today it's all stir fry
and stir fry a little more squeeze a
lemon over it for that Tangy taste and
enjoy